Dan santis is paying people that that
shocked me I couldn't believe do we
publicly see who who he's paying Riley
Gaines is a good example I didn't know
that really the D santis campaign is
paying Riley gains wow for for
Consulting just two weeks before or two
weeks after she endorsed him so you know
the timing was interesting but I find
that practice two weeks after she
endorsed him she gets paid by his
campaign $10,000 interesting so I find
that practice gross you know know and I
and I like I that was something that I
wanted because I went and spent I went
and spent the day doing a documentary
for our my tenant media show called in
the arena where we go and we show this
process shout out tenant and I was
accused of being disloyal because I was
going out with the vake but I just want
to tell an interesting story and he's
the only guy that had campaign uh events
today right and they were all over the
state and it was very interesting how
how how else can we look bunch of gen Z
bunch of gen Z kids by the way pay well
no that were showing up to this and
saying that they found him through Tik
Tok and I'm not on no oh so VES events
were stacked by and large with Tik Tok
kids he's clever uh some more results
have just come in a little bit uh V's
still in fourth and uh but he's within
15 votes of Nikki Haley I gotta be
honest I'd be really happy if Donald
Trump wins resoundingly and V's in
second place Trump's number so far I
just want to say
nice I just don't like the paid
influencer model pay you for your
endorsement model call that corruption
that used to be called like plain and
simple like corrupt like you do that in
politics you pay someone for an
endorsement you call that corruption do
you know any other people that he's
paying that are prominent influencers or
do you not want to well there are there
are ways there there are ways that these
campaigns are shielding the name winter
is in with less than 1% of votes the New
York Times has called Donald Donald
Trump the winner of the Iowa caucus I
was told I was told by team DeSantis
that the santis was going to win that
didn't happen wow wow less than 1% votes
in no way are there other 732 I don't
understand still very is my mic even on
yeah I think you're a little quiet and
so was shame
yeah well that's that's good for both of
them actually maybe they're in that
screaming M oh Ryan binkley's got two
votes Bley please I just want VI to beat
Nikki how call he's he's with 12 votes
of beating Nikki Haley that's incredible
that's a good sign on you got this I got
to be honest I I just
hope fails the race has been called by
the Associated Press the race was called
before most of the votes were reported
which often means the call was based on
polls and other data oh okay so so we
can go home now is done I no I think
it's I I I think we're all happy to hear
that uh Donald Trump won of course he
was going to win he's at 70% his number
is only increasing but the the race that
matters is the cultural race and that is
I would like to see the crush D santis
and Nikki haly CBS CBS News Now calling
New York CBS News
CNN Trump campaign officially shares the
AP message that he won I I personally
find VI to be the superior candidate but
I know that politics is a popularity
contest I can accept that and Donald
Trump is massively popular what do you
think Alex particularly you and anybody
that wants to talk about it as a VI
Donald Trump ticket regardless of who's
I mean I think Donald Trump is the the
lead I think V has certainly positioned
himself for an incredible future is it
in 2024 on the ticket I don't know um
but I think we have a lot of great
options I'm a big fan of Dr Ben Carson I
think he's been a tremendous uh asset to
to our movement and he's a really great
man um I think V certainly is should be
considered um but I do believe that
President Trump has made up his mind and
we'll probably uh find out who is it
we'll probably find out that uh sooner
than later and this primary should wrap
up sooner than later because you know
Joe Biden just posted his financials
that he raised this last quarter $117
million he gets to save all of his money
and prepare for the general election
this primary so far $250 million has
been spent and look at that margin right
now and so we are just blowing money
that we need in November and so we need
some of these Jokers to drop out and so
we can take the fight to Joe bid man
you're you're so right this was a
spectacular waste of money it's gonna be
this if it's they're going to call it in
like 29 seconds and how much money was
300 votes coming in well how much money
was spend here Chris Christie was
talking about it on the um leaked audio
right like when he was he didn't know he
was Live Well he was he was tallying
$200 million r s has spent $99 million
in the state
99 million and he's got 75 V5 votes yeah
do you work for Trump's campaign I do
not work for Trump's campaign but I uh
am close with most of the folks over
there uh been blessed to become uh
friends with the president I'm excited
to see him in in a few minutes here uh
he's going to be in great spirits and in
great
mood I do want Brian Bley has two votes
now I want to mention I discount I do
need to point out the uh uh while you
may be upset that Ron spent all of that
money uh when Bloomberg was running and
everyone in the country was laughing and
he spent half a billion dollars doing it
just understand he spent a lot of that
money on YouTube channels that hated him
and so congratulations funding the
people who spread the message that you
suck yeah so understand when these
people are spending money it's great for
the for the uh cultural ecosystem what
they're trying to do is that campaigns
like Des santis I don't know if he's
buying ads in social media the way
Bloomberg was doing but they're trying
to counter the message of people who are
saying Bloomberg sucks it doesn't work
so all he ends up doing is giving money
to people who hate him to make more
shows about why he's bad so it doesn't
really work the way they want
congratulations on on wasting that money
is it is the disantis what's he spending
the 99 million on is it TV commercials I
bet it's a lot of TV so he had he for
months he was saying we're gonna win you
know please find this clip you got to
show your audience this clip they say
Ron how do you pronounce your last name
is it D santis or do santis and he goes
It's pronounced winner you got to find
the this clip you got to find this clip
got him can I ask something it's
pronounced winner as as someone who's
been watching online and chuckling to
myself what was it that do you live in
Florida I do so what was it that like
sent you over the edge with the team D
santis I think how
uh CU nobody goes harder than you well
they certainly were a lot of fun to spar
with early on just because you know I'm
as a professional Twitter troll I try to
get people's skin and the second you
like on once somebody shows that their
skin is like has been breached you just
keep pressing it and you press in and so
it just becomes a lot of fun and so uh
they reacted to everything we tried to
bait them into fights that weren't
important and then they spend days and
days on a new cycle that uh was
completely irrelevant to the campaign
and they couldn't help themselves they
engaged every single time they fought on
every single issue you know I think Tim
pointed out a really important one he
said you know the AI fight so they get
caught making a video with Dr fouchy and
Donald Trump hugging in Ai and
Incredibly shady and Tim P called him
out Senator JD Vance called him out Josh
Holly called it out they said and then
their response is well Donald Trump
shared this meme of Ronda santis riding
a rhinocerous it's basically the same
thing and like they would they die on
their Hills they refuse to say I was
wrong and they they just push in and
push in and uh whoa we got good news fa
is within nine votes of Nikki Haley come
on yes get it get it I hope Ryan Binkley
beats Nikki
Haley Alex in your experience trolling
have you gained troll resistance are you
able to resist do well I grew up in
video game culture you know so you log
on you play Call of Duty you play you
know whatever game you play and you sit
in your with your buddies and you say
the meanest things you can say to each
other for you know all day every day and
then you get off and you you know see
each other at school the next day and
your best friends right like I don't
words don't hurt me so like I don't
really care if somebody's like
uh you know they call me AB 35k or they
say I have no upper lip or whatever it
may be like like I appreciate the
attacks and I find humor in the attacks
and so I like the game but you get these
guys take it so personally and they're
so offended by it and they react
emotionally inste logically and we just
play with them my conspiracy theory is
that the people running dis sanist
campaign are Trump supporters and they
got together and said what can we do to
sabotage Ronda santis because if you
look at what they're doing it literally
makes no sense no sense I I don't want
call out high-profile individuals who
don't want to get involved in fights
they don't need to be involved in but
we've had guests on this show who are
prominent conservative personalities and
different range of array of spaces what
I mean by that is like being as vague as
possible is like an Entertainer perhaps
and they say things like when they show
up to the studio they'll be like hey I'm
getting attacked by these disantis
people what's going on and I'm just like
what did you say I don't know and I'm
just like well there you go welcome to
Ronda campaign attack everybody and
insult them and be condescending and
mean and apparently that's that's what
they think's going to get him the votes
it's oh with two votes from Nikki Haley
oh V you got to crush Nikki come on come
on they it's nimrata that's right we're
supposed to use our real names that's
right Nikki Haley says we must use our
real names online oh yeah so this is
online and you must call her by her real
no Nikki haly no Nikki Haley just jumped
17 none what ran got six what percent
are we at now or is it give you a real
time update 1% of votes oh it's still
one one I just dm' you the video on
Twitter oh okay I sent you the article
about it too on Twitter
n did you know this yes she changed her
husband's name to Michael Yes it Nikki
Haley uh it was Bill or something yeah
it was like Bill and she's like I'm
gonna call you Mike she like I'm G going
to call you Mike she said I'm going to
call you Big Mike so there's been rumors
for years there's been rumors for years
of alleged Affairs Nick like there's a
staffer that came forward and said they
had an affair with Nikki and I don't
think it was an affair if this guy
allowed his wife to change his name I
don't think it's an affair I think he
might be well whatever it is look I mean
like there's levels of this there's like
there's levels of being insulted there's
like first like your wife hyphenating
instead of taking your name and then
there's like you taking her name and
then there's like her changing your
first
name and that's where they are as a
couple you're up here like I dumpy
Michael it is it is getting brutal Nikki
Haley is now well above V so early I
suspect Nikki Haley pulls ahead of Ron
really and Ron finishes in third place
with about 15% you think V will be in
fourth look I think V is going to be
very close to Ron he campaign so hard
look look money still matters and you
know V has probably been the most uh
Frugal of the first of the top four
candidates and uh he's putting up an
interesting fight but Ron wasted almost
a hundred million and it's probably
going to be very close to aake in the
race thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 P.M
and become a member over at timcast.net